These are the politicians who are profiled to run for the presidency of 2,026,
two years before the next general elections,
2,026 political candidates are already
preparing to run for the presidency of Peru.
One of them is Fiorela Molinelli,
former executive president of the social security of health and
former minister of development and inclusion who confirmed in a
dialogue with 1/2 that she will tempt the presidential chair
through her modern force party or deal with 4 fundamental issues,
citizen security,
health,
education and economic reactivation.
On the other hand,
the former regional governor of Ica,
Fernando Sillonis announced that he will
resume his political career for the 2026 elections.
In an interview with 1/2 local he said that he was waiting for the
invitation of some political group to start his campaign I don't have
any party affiliation either I didn't have it in Ica I was invited I
won the elections and I was ratified Something similar I am willing to do now.
Susel walls the congresswoman for democratic change together for
Peru in an interview with Rosa Maria Palacios said she was going to
be a pre-candidate for the presidency for the recently created party.
First people we are registered,
we have all the legality and now what I am doing is walking.
To strengthen district and regional bases.
Another candidate may appear in the party that surpasses me.
In the same way are people like Guillermo Bermejo and Roberto Chabra,
who have already announced their intentions to aspire to the presidency.
Another candidate is Verónica Mendoza,
who despite leaving the presidency of the new Peru
for the good life continues to be her main figure.